let's hear from tb12 himself as tom
brady has just addressed the media
holy cow
what was your thought on another
reception tonight for the fans of new
england sorry i couldn't hear you what
are your thoughts of your at the
reception tonight when you took the
field the fans it was great it was great
that's a great night of football
a um
obviously very tough game
uh came down to just a couple plays but
um glad we were able to win
and i'm sorry to keep you guys waiting
i wasn't anticipating this
were you surprised or did you think
you'd get i mean you got a few jers
while you were playing but when you came
out for warm-ups and people went nuts
cheering chanting did that surprise you
or uh i'm not surprised i just i tried
not to
predict what was going to happen and how
it feel and had a few emotional moments
this week just thinking about all the
people that have
really meant so much to me in my life
and
that are a part of this community and
i'm just very grateful for
you know amazing time here and
like i said my football journey took me
somewhere else but i'm really enjoying
that and great to get a win three in one
i know to make it about the game but you
know three and one against a really good
football team tonight's what we want to
get done
can you discuss your look at your your
interactions with bill on the field and
i guess in the locker room after the
game yeah um i mean all those are
personal so we've had a personal
relationship and um
you know for 20 plus years so he drafted
me here and
i've had a lot of personal conversations
that should remain that way and they're
very private and i would say
so much is made of of our relationship
and um
you know as i said earlier this week you
know from a player's standpoint you just
expect the coach to give you everything
he's gotten as a i'm sure as a player
that's what he was hoping for me but
um
nothing's really accurate that i ever
see it's all
kind of uh
you know definitely doesn't come from my
personal feelings or beliefs and i have
a lot of respect for him as a coach and
obviously a lot of respect for this
organization and
um
you know all the different people here
that try to make it successful you
surprised to see him after the second
time i guess afterwards
no we just uh no we just said we'll
catch up after the game for a little bit
different going up against some of these
guys in practice and now you go up
against running in the game
is there a different feel when you do
that
um
i mean it doesn't count in practice so
nothing matters if you give touchdowns
or interceptions so it all counts out
here
was a tough hard-fought game it was very
typical
patriot type weather um
you know very tough to come into the
environment i thought the fans did a
great job at
that that little
what they call that horn foghorn
whatever that thing's loud this could be
you don't think about it much when
you're you know trying to uh
you know when the when the defense on
the field i just happened to be on the
field when that thing was going off so
they uh it's a great home field
advantage the fans are amazing and um
just happy to
you know for for for our team personally
just for us to get a win in the really
tough environment it's tough to do in
the nfl
you ran out of the tunnel and you did
your 100 yard run that you've done so
many times but you ended in the opposite
end zone
what was going through your head what
was your first thought there well i
couldn't run through the normal tunnel
so
yeah it just happened to be the opposite
way tonight and i was just fun a lot of
emotions and it's a very uh very
emotional week just
again
these guys are like my brothers you know
what i mean and i gotta
you know there's two groups of people i
all of my bucks teammates that i love
and
and i'm going to battle with every week
and then there's another group of guys
that i see and those are my friends that
i've been with for a long time matt
slater and
kyle van noy and dante hightower and
john and devin and david andrews and
hoyer and
um there's a whole crew josh and
just you know these are these other
people that i've shared my life with and
uh very grateful for
everything that they've
uh kind of uh contributed to my life
very blessed
being able to
to get the nfl passing record you know
what did that mean for you tonight i
just think it's an amazing um
statistic and that so many people can
share it with me so
quarterback doesn't throw and catch
quarterback can just throw it and it's
yards
passing yards have to be caught so i
just hope that everybody who caught
passes from me over the years
just had a little smile on their face
tonight just knowing that they
contributed to you know a very cool
record and there's some people that have
kind of preceded it by name
you know drew brees who i look up to is
a hell of a guy
great player peyton manning who's one of
my all-time favorites brett favre dan
marino
um
but obviously you know my teammates who
caught all these passes
over the years
mean an awful lot to me
[Music]
tonight what do you think of the way
belichick and that defense depend they
did a good job they did a good job i
mean it was it was a tough game
hard-fought game we ran the ball well
moved it we just didn't get it in the
red zone you know we had a few
kind of costly uh
drive killing
kind of mistakes that limited us getting
really scoring touchdowns it would have
been a lot different but
you know just proud of our teams tough
weather
um
you know just very typical day we had to
grind it up defensive attack what you
expected from belichick knowing him so
well
they did a good job yeah they did a good
job i mean it's they they got a good
team they got good cover players they
got
you know they got a good rush
got some good hits on me tonight so i'll
be a little sore tomorrow tom your
thoughts on max jones the other day you
said you hadn't seen much of mac jones
but now you have so just your
impressions of his performance tonight
what are you able to watch did a great
job did a great job i think that offense
does a great job josh really dialed up
some good plays too so
they kind of hit everything i saw him
come in and a couple reverse passes and
throw back and
um
they did a good job but uh
in the end it always comes down to a
couple plays
happy we made them had ryan made a huge
kick you know made a few big ones last
year for us
um now nick got a good hit on that one
there at the end it just was a little
bit left
if this was your last game at gillette
stadium how do you kind of put put into
words what this place meant to you and
is it a little sweeter that you were
able to
pull out a win
it's been a great stadium you know for
me for a long time so i don't know what
the future holds you know obviously
there could be an opportunity to come
back here so
we'll see i i feel like always be a part
of this community and
um
i'll be i'll be up here quite a bit when
it's all said and then when i retire i'm
sure there'll be you know a lot of time
for uh you know i have a lot of friends
up here and it's a great place and again
my kids were born on beacon street in
the city and
um
you know it's just it's amazing been an
amazing place for me it still is and i
obviously see a lot of
familiar friendly faces and uh it's
great to see you guys too hey tom you
talked about preparation and how
emotional it was this week so for
everything that you expected and then as
it turned out tonight what was
the difference in and how you had to try
to lock in this week and how it all
turned out
i feel good that we won you know i feel
good that we won i i think that uh
again i didn't try to it was just some
emotional moments thinking about coming
up here and playing and
um again i just i know why it's tough to
come in here and and uh win a game you
know all these years they this team does
a great job they make you earn it
they're not gonna win every game um
but you know it's a tough football
environment the crowds into it
i'm just i'm really happy we got to win
[Music]
a tough football environment indeed but
chris what did you notice about tom
brady and his demeanor when he came into
this game when you saw all the pregame
footage of who he was shaking hands with
what did you notice about him i'm just
amazed with how like accommodating he is
right such a big moment the pressure of
the game the magnitude of the whole
situation you know nbc pregame show
where everybody's there and he's just
saying hi to everybody oh drew brees
come to me you know hey we'll talk here
hey ex-player this guy hello i just i'm
amazed by his calmness and then he shows
it on the football field they don't give
many big plays he kind of just can
continues to play a really clean
football game and of course battles and
is so clutch brady's amazing never seen
anything like him the clutches
quarterback i've ever seen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports